it wasn't it didn't start out well I
always want to go into to attain the
troops but when I got landing with CBS
they said no yeah yeah millions all
proper you're not going anywhere so when
the troops came home I'd show it got
cancer that's all another different
story I want to talk about that story oh
yeah oh it's it's interesting it's a
great story so I I go to 229 pounds
Marine base we pull up in a limo we blow
anything up down and anything down up
and I said I'm gonna like this place so
we go into George Lopez there and George
Miller a couple of comics and I said so
I go up to Jeff Altman and he's the host
and I go to shake his head and he blows
me and gives me a hi hat walks away I go
what's this so they say that later in
the show they said listen Jeff we have
this kid I've got a purple hat he's back
now and we want to unite him with his
mother in the US that's kind of corny
and he walks off a girl out of it and so
I go hey now you don't cooperate well
you know I miss my family well that's
great because we brought your mother
meant to be like yeah the crowd goes
crazy and they said do you want his job
I said yeah give me a dollar more than
him and I took over to Sunday comics
that night so I mean so then they say we
go from like a hundred to seven in the
ratings and they said what do you want
myself what should hire this kid Kenny
Rogers and there's my head writer and I
go what's he written I said we brought
me a couple of letters from prison and
what I want so they hire them and they
fly him out I pick him up at the airport
we drive to my place in Marina del Rey
and he goes which floor was yours they
all of them you know I was living in
like a three million dollar place at the
time he goes this is incredible so we
get jammed up for three days and the
third day comes down he's our bag W
[ __ ] he goes I love you a man but he
goes I got a wife a kid now I can't [ __ ]
this up I really need the job okay
alright we'll go to work we drive the
[ __ ] man we poke up my pocket space at
the top of a roof it's great and we're
going by a current of fear which used to
be Marie Paule which is you see you
people suck you shouldn't even have all
these offices kill him in ratings they
get all the stress so we go down and I
said to my secretary hold all my calls
we go in my office in this three couches
so why three couch and I said when
people come over they might wanna
right so they say okay mr. Clark they're
ready for Kenny so I bring Kenny to meet
the producers and I said just come by
the office when you're done so 20
minutes later he comes person is my you
know I can't believe it you're the
[ __ ] boss you know what they told me
my job is to make you happy oh god he
was great well that show was a great
show but there was a crazy thing
attached to that with your agent that
wound up [ __ ] over not just you but a
slew of people one guy Oh Bob Williams
oh boy what was that Starr agencies I
would've what the [ __ ] was my wife yeah
well we [ __ ] everybody and a little
Seinfeld to sign I think side felt when
I swapped when I get Lenny and I was
making all sorts of money they said you
need an agent I said I want Seinfeld and
Leno's agent you know and at the same
time he was doing both of them so I
figured these guys are the biggest guys
in the business and he screwed them but
they got their money back I was like the
the lowest guy on the totem pole so I
got to go fight two million dollars
Jesus I mean and it was bad I find what
people were trying to keep you from
killing yeah I went I found out where
it's kids went to school and everything
you know but you can't do that you gotta
let it go yeah but it took a long
whatever happen is that guy still in the
business country he's in country music
oh they didn't know yeah they didn't get
the memo
[ __ ] oh yeah it was I was I was I was so
pissed I mean because not only did I
have the show but when I went there
everything was going good and I invited
Barry Diller to at Fox he was the head
of Fox at the time I would throw a party
for the entire cast the crew everyone at
Fox and they all showed up and you know
I had I showcased a bunch of my friends
so they could get jobs and Barry Delta
goes from you've really done a great job
for us I said I really loved you know
working with you mr. Diller he said okay
so later in the night this this Asian
man came up to me goes you know everyone
likes you but I don't get it
I said well stick around hop sing you'll
catch you on
and I didn't think anything of it the
next morning I chipped they'd give me a
like I'm million dollar bonus and they
raised my my weekly salary I'm it was a
lot of money he was like over two
million bucks and I was going to Dallas
to do the tack deck Texas State Fair
would one of the man trellis is not not
early no the other ones just some crazy
name and I'll and then Dallas and he
calls me said I got good news and bad no
sisters give me the bad news he goes did
you have a problem with a Chinese guy
last night I said oh yeah yeah I guess
so I guess well that's Barry Diller's
right-hand man you're done he they they
threw you off the lot they said I said
what's the good news here we got your
money and I go I want my job I said let
me apologize to the guy I didn't mean it
I didn't know I think oh no they've
already taken all stuff out of your
office and put it in boxes and you're
done and now I do the State Fair and I'm
going man it sucks you know I mean I
want to get back to LA to try and
salvage the career you know because I
mean this is another network that I'm no
longer welcome at just from one
conversation I've I've got stories I
wish I'd never opened my mouth I'm
screwed yeah no one's [ __ ] up my life
more than myself and not intentional
right so what we're doing the State Fair
and this horse with a buckboard goes out
of control and the horses swing and the
buck woods coming towards the reviewing
stand so I grabbed him the Mandrell girl
and get her out of her just this the
whole thing is wiped out and I'm said
did you get that did they get that on
tape you know but that was that was the
end of my career at Fox
that was crazy from one conversation
where a guy said he didn't like you how
about this about one of them I'm at
I have Lenny at CBS and it was doing
good and then the court the Gulf War
came out that that killed me and then
they brought me back and we were hanging
on by a thread and they said listen
forget about the show we think you're a
great actor let's give you a movie
theater really it says yeah we're gonna
give you first picture two million
dollars and then then expects you know
first of a million and then to me and
then to me five million dollars three
picture deal you know I can't believe
this happen is that one question can ya
then he said hey I make a believe I'm
having fun with you and I get out
everyone hey man I was only kidding that
was that was a pretty good get out and I
and I got I just got to myself I may get
dollars but just by being funny and and
it and I said I'll never do that again
so like that's gonna happen right Joe
gets better
I read for this movie true romance you
know oh yeah oh yeah so I mean I get I
get clean I get straight up I work on
the lines I'm ready so I go over and
it's Ridley Scott of his brother one of
the famous Scott the rectus a kid comes
out I see how many people in there
there's 13 that's because I was like to
know how many are in the room cuz you
don't wanna go in it
so I walk in and and I look at the paper
he goes you ready oh yeah I throw the
script on the floor he goes I guess you
already goes hit The Times was hitting
from the left
I was hitting frightened I said you
better like it cuz you're never gonna
lick [ __ ] again I guess whoa whoa whoa
was it say lick [ __ ] I said right in
the script he picks up say so like [ __ ]
I said well if you like it you look at
right get out get out of my office again
so I'm driving home my agent Cosby says
what did you do to my god he said you're
a brilliant actor but you gotta get off
the drugs I said I haven't done coke in
two weeks I was serious for this pot
who's he get it to Tom Sizemore is bad
guys who were like yeah up to the neck
in cocaine yeah oh my god that's crazy
that they got that upset I'm having fun
I'm pretending I'm laughing with you I
make them believe I'm having fun with
you on it just because I thought we were
and giving you offering you millions of
dollars oh my god isn't this nice you
know that's a problem with people that
have so much power they want you to suck
their dick every second of the day
and as soon as there's any deviation at
all they think you're oh you think
you're a smart ass you're done in just
one you know how like a power you know
you know you know how guys sleep with
women you know to get ahead I had a
woman told me she wanted to [ __ ] me but
she was hideous and it was at night in
the morning you know go Jesus I'm not
even drunk
[Laughter]
get that job